here now is the author of american
marxism the number one best-selling book
of all of last year also the host of
life liberty levin the number one show
sunday night here on fox and his own
radio show nationally syndicated uh the
great one mark levin all right we don't
have
a lot of time but i have really two
topics i want you to weigh in on number
one the supreme court issue and number
two this ministry of of truth that
mayorkis is talking about
first of all
people have said a lot of things about
this supreme court issue i'm listening
to these democrats couple of things
the democrats don't believe a woman is a
woman right didn't they just nominate
somebody and get somebody confirmed who
couldn't define what a woman is without
a biologist
so it's clear if you follow their logic
which is very difficult
a woman is only a woman
if she believes in abortion or gets an
abortion that is what you have to
conclude from the democrat party chuck
schumer screams at the top of his lungs
which is a very ugly scene
saying that this will not stand this the
will not say what will not stand chuck
the constitution will not stand then i
hear some of the left-wing women
senators or birthing peoples or aborting
people senators i guess
they get up and they say things like
we're going to have a patchwork system i
guess they're not familiar with
federalism the 10th amendment and so
forth we have a patchwork system in our
country for all kinds of things
then they say well a woman will have to
travel to a state that allows abortion
under certain circumstances and so forth
and so on these are the people who are
bussing illegal aliens all over the
country every corner of the country
flying them bussing them training them
it's no big deal but apparently it's a
huge inconvenience if you're going to
have an abortion to go to the next door
state or something like this the
democrat party is insane the democrat
party is a war with our institutions
it's destroying them
immediately bernie sanders wants to
destroy the senate and his sidekick
elizabeth warren
when it comes to the filibuster rule let
me make something clear
this is not the united states of the
democrat party this is the united states
of america damn it and we the american
people have a say in what goes on in our
country keep your damn hands off our
constitution they say they're worried
about our children they're destroying
our children's minds in our elementary
schools and middle schools they say they
care about women they're destroying
women's sports title ix and so forth
they don't even recognize womanhood they
say they care about citizens they're
destroying citizenship on the southern
border and elsewhere the democrat party
is out to undermine this country they've
been threatening this court for years
threatening its independence threatening
individual justices have destroyed the
confirmation process destroyed people's
names we don't have to take this from
these people and women of america you
should rise up chuck schumer just said
he represents 100 million women he
doesn't represent 100 million women that
goofball he doesn't represent any women
as far as i'm concerned and this whole
thing seems contrived to me have you
noticed how well organized it is they
get their leaker the guy puts out the
first draft all of a sudden people are
showing up like they're coming right out
of the woods they show up they got their
contrived signs they got their talking
points and one other thing that's very
very important
joe biden said today schumer said today
these legal analysts have said today
this will destroy marriage same-sex
marriage have they read the opinion this
is in the opinion
unable to show concrete reliance on roe
and casey themselves the solicitor
general meaning the lawyer for the
government suggested overruling those
decisions would threaten the court's
presidents holding that the due process
clause protects other rights
this is not correct for reasons we've
already discussed
as even the casey plurality recognizes
abortion is a unique act because it
terminates life for potential life
abortion is inherently different for
marital intimacy marriage or procreation
and they say we want to make abundantly
clear we're not touching any other
rights because they know about the
demagogues and the media and so forth
what happened to ginsburg why don't they
quote her in the 1992 new york
university law review article roe halted
a political process that was moving in a
reformed direction and thereby i believe
prolonged divisiveness and deferred
stable settlement of the issue here's
what's going on
there is no federal constitutional right
to abortion
period they amended the constitution
without amending the constitution
period and so now what are they trying
to do now they're trying to tell us that
science is in science the same people
want to mandate masks and vaccines is
that a baby in the womb
is that a viable baby in the womb
at the very last minute yes
it's not a salami sandwich it's a viable
baby in the womb and we have states and
governors that say you can abort that
baby even though it's viable it's not a
choice it's a human being so to the
democrat party women aren't women
babies aren't babies this is insanity
now as for the
truth as for this this thing they want
to set up the ministry of truth
we have a first amendment they ought to
abide by that that's actually in the
constitution we need ministry of truth
against the government it used to be
called a free press
we don't have a free press they're
utterly and completely corrupt they're
in the back pocket of the democrat party
in this american marxist movement if we
had a free press
that would be the ministry of truth but
they're all corrupt for the most part
that's it
you're supposed to say that's it i'm
done what happened to the i'm done part
anyway that's why we call you the great
one the great one mark levin all right
life liberty levin sunday night right
here on fox don't miss it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else